[Music]
Hey look guys my name is the cheddar
welcome to 20/20 sir it's the start of a
new year and one of the things that I
really like to do at the beginning else
pretty much every year is sit down and
plan what it is I'm gonna do this year
and since my full time job and career at
the moment is YouTube I guess that means
that we're going to sit down and talk
about menus what we're gonna do this
year because there's a lot of stuff
going on my channel there's a lot of
issues and things that I don't like the
way that they are going and then there's
also obviously a lot of really cool
stuff that I'm really excited to
actually do so what I've done is created
this kind of list here of things that I
want to discuss with you guys but I want
to emphasize the fact that I'm
discussing it with you guys you guys are
the supporters of this channel you're
the viewers the other the audience that
I make these videos for whilst I do make
videos that try to include as wide of an
audience as possible view people that
are subscribed to this channel the
people who are watching these videos the
other reason why I make these videos in
the first place and if I'm making
something that you're not interested in
or if you think I could do a better job
then I'm all ears I'm here to kind of
improve I'm still new to time doing
YouTube as a full-time job and that's
obviously a billion things that I really
want to do that I haven't had the chance
to get to just yet but in general I kind
of need your help so I always see this
as a bit of like a performance review
not really like a performance review
let's not go all corporate on this like
I don't want that up enough that but
just like in general you know what would
you like to see on this channel what do
you think that I'm I haven't done that
you want me to do let's kind of talk
about that and that's what the comments
of a comment section below is actually
four big funny fighters disable all
comments for this video so there are
three different parts to my channel and
I do maybe want to include more but at
the at the moment as like the way that
this stands right now what is the
channel project what is this channel on
youtube you know we have the Gammage and
series first and foremost
probably the most important cereal on my
channel it's the the the thing that I
think most of you are here for I know
there's a lot there's also a huge amount
of people that are here but like just
say plus possible games at all but the
game engine series is kind of like the
project that we're working on right now
we're building a game engine called
hazel so the way that that's going I
mean there's there's true kind of ways
that I see that there's the personal
development that I actually do for that
so in other words what I actually do is
I develop hazel in my own time and then
that's actually available on development
branch for patrons that's kind of the
meat of the engine that's in a way I
think where the engine is heading
towards because that development that I
do offline is really important because I
then take what I've written and I
converted into a format that I can
actually present in a video in like a
tutorial format which is kind of what
the game engine the series on YouTube
actually is so there's that but then
apart from us kind of building this game
engine which we are doing kind of slowly
because there's a lot of concepts that I
want to cover the lot of things I want
to do and also sometimes it's very
difficult for me to kind of adequately
split the time between me wanting to jam
in all these exciting features and
actually develop stuff for the game
engine development branch right the
havel development project and then also
convert something to a video format for
you guys because the thing that I think
most people don't realize is that I'm a
software engineer and I'm not working
for a company right now I'm working for
myself so if I'm just spending all of my
time you know making videos on how to
draw 2d graphics in the screen for
example which is where we're off to in
the game engine series which is fine by
the way I'm not complaining then I'm
just not gonna experience any kind of
you know personal growth and it's just
gonna be not real it's gonna be a little
bit wasted on me I mean it's not
completely wasted but you know I need
that balance of actually developing
stuff that is new to me or learning new
things and without that it kind of
stunts my growth a little bit as a
software engineer and as someone kind of
interested in game mentions so that's
kind of you know I it's always a
challenge to kind of manage my time by
myself since I'm new to that and I might
make some videos talking about how I
wanted us to do that and kind of the
lessons that I've learned in the last
half year or so doing this full-time
let me know what you think about that
because my plan as well for this year is
to probably
trying to include more videos that that
aren't just completely 100% about you
know programming so that's kind of the
idea though it's kind of it's always
it's always a balancing game with like
ba-lakay do I work on hazel Devon do I
kind of do stuff that I'm interested in
or do I kind of sit down and try and
make this kind tutorial series and
obviously you know I have to do both
it's not like and I want to do both the
reason I'm doing this game engine series
is because I really want to but yeah
sometimes it becomes a little bit of a
challenge so I am aware that like the
game engine series may be progressing a
little bit slowly I want to fix that and
one of the ways that I'm gonna fix that
actually is the reason why I think it's
a little bit difficult to make videos
sometimes before that is because there
are in almost concepts in that series I
mean I'm sure everyone's aware of that
like some of the things that we need to
eventually do are huge and then I'm
gonna be done in one video then I'm
gonna be done in like a reasonable
amount of time in videos end up going to
45 minutes long because I have a lot to
say and I want to get it all down so
what I want to do is involve the OpenGL
Series in that and in fact I want to do
more standalone videos what I mean by
that is I don't want you know it is a
really good example we're up to batch
rendering in the game engine series we
need to make a video in which we
implement batch render is another in
other words basically bashing 2d quads
together into a single draw call instead
of actually you know drawing each quad
separately as a separate draw that's not
the most complicated of concepts but
it's also not simple and to explain it
as well to people who do not know what
is right I'm the way that a lot of you
people watching this series know what
that is and you you know you're on a
higher level than many others but for
someone who doesn't know what batch
rendering is why do you like what on
earth is going on there how do we do
this enter this doesn't make sense to me
how do we control this how to control
that how does it work that requires kind
of sitting down and drawing some
diagrams and probably talking about well
this is why this is good as Weis is bad
you know this is why we don't want this
this is how we can do this these are the
kind of consequences of doing it this
way but in other word
you know that it helps us here or
whatever to sit down and do that in a
good way that takes time and I don't
want that to just be like okay game
engines there is episode 60 batch
rendering that is not the kind of
education that is gonna help someone who
is new to this because the game engine
itself hazel whilst it is still like
comparatively quite a simple code base
it's still a lot more than many people
are used to and you know just like if I
was to take say Unreal Engine and then
try to put in a level generation system
that would be a lot more complicated
than if I had my own engine or if I had
a completely blank sandbox kind of
canvas whatever and then I wanted to
test out some like Perlin noise Jenna
like I don't know a level generation for
example that was part that was part of
the actual engine not like just a script
you know that is kind of what we're
dealing with here where to someone to
kind of compete be like okay well this
batch rendering hey watch me jam it into
this engine that has like a lot of other
things that's not ideal at all and so
what I want to do is in fact what I have
done and it'll be a video probably
coming out next week hopefully is I've
made a very bare-bones base OpenGL
library that was inspired well it's very
much inspired by hazel so it's got some
faithful systems like the layers in the
event system for example that's pretty
much it what it what it is is just a
very basic OpenGL library that lets you
just write OpenGL code in your main
application and that's pretty much it so
it's really simple if I want you for
example oh cool there's a you know oh I
want to test out opengl uniform buffers
yeah I don't but I don't want to set up
like this whole OpenGL thing by myself I
want to just be able to open up a file
and write some weapon gel card and then
you know have maybe some utility
libraries around as well like for things
like loading shaders but I want
something where I can just play around
with OpenGL that's kind of what this
base library is and I'm going to
on github and everything and there'll be
a video on like how I made it and what
what it contains and everything probably
next week but my plan with that is to be
like a cable batch rendering let's take
that let's kind of start with this blank
canvas of OpenGL Ness which is the kind
of this base library and then add stuff
onto that and then that's pretty much
gonna be you know great because that's
all that project will be all that video
will be is just going from nothing to
just having a little bit of that
rendering using OpenGL commands
everything is visible and when the card
gets published it's kind of all there
all right there's no kind of like okay
well you know I have to go through all
this engine code to figure out how to
eat good because integrating and
designing a system is true very
different things and I guess I kind of
want to emphasize that so I'm really
excited to kind of bring back that
OpenGL series and then hopefully next
week if not the week after I want to
actually make that batch rendering
episode in the OpenGL series it's kind
of the standalone batch rendering
episode and then we're gonna tie in the
game engine series and be like okay now
that we know how this works let's tie
this into the game engine series and
let's actually integrate this into hazel
because that's a whole different
ballgame and that's kind of in a way
what we've been doing what we've been
doing with a little like these libraries
we've been taking stuff in and
integrating them into hazel and that's
you know that's my probably probably my
preferred way to do things just because
it tends to just get really complicated
if you want to teach something in a huge
engine right I'm sure that makes sense
to a lot of you as well and that's only
gonna get worse as time goes on so I've
kind of been just thinking about how we
can make this better alright so that
being said that's what the OpenGL series
is gonna do as we get into more graphics
things because I want to there's a bunch
of things that I want to do for the game
engine series Mac and Linux is gonna
come very soon I really want to get that
done within the next month or so because
the earlier we do that pretty much the
better and also I know that a lot of
people have been asking for it so Mac
and Linux is gonna happen continuous
integration and things like you know
just you know maintaining a repository
with issues and tracking and stuff like
that let me know what you think about
that and if you want to see a lot of
that I'm not sure how many of you are
actually interested in
kind of their maintenance the DevOps I
guess side of the game mentioned series
right or if you just purely interested
in the C++ code which is fine just let
me know in the comments but I do want to
include at least one video on CI or
something like that because I want to
get that up and running as well and of
course I need to show everything I want
to show everything that I'm doing I
don't want anything to kind of be behind
the scenes so that's something that will
happen and then in general the like the
wet the area or the place that I want to
take the game engine series to is a very
art focused place and that's what I mean
by that is I want hazel to be something
primarily to begin with that lets you
create art right so in other words I
want the renderer to be really good and
that's why we're focusing on that first
now you know let's picture like a scene
I want hazel to be something that you
can use to make a beautiful scene with
like you know all the kind of latest
graphics spacious but then also it means
the building blocks to actually create a
level for example and then save it and
serialize it and whatever that's going
to be step one in the grand plan but
then there's also the interactivity kind
of section so in other words we need
like a scripting language to be able to
make a game like that kind of flappy
bird clone that I made which was the
game that I made in an hour using hazel
right I'll link the video up there um
you know this there's two parts to this
as them I really just want to make it on
one hand I want to make hazel like this
kind of 3d rendering masterpiece right
in which you can create 3d scenes and
stuff but then I also want to obviously
make it so that we can make a quick game
like flappy bird in hazel very very
easily and that was the point of making
that game in an hour to kind of see you
know to see what exactly it would take
and what we need to improve and hazel to
make that a lot easier so that's you
know that there's this kind of fork in
the road and I want to take it to both
places I obviously can't um so let me
know what your thoughts are about that
if you would rather see kind of
interaction or if you just want to dive
into 3d graphics what will probably end
up happening is on the development
branch I'll probably do both because
I've already gone down that pretty
graphics route and you know there's all
things like Vulcan for example I added
in Vulcan to hazel as well which I
was gonna release patrons and I still am
definitely this month I just need I just
want to polish off the card a little
because it's not completely finished and
I don't want people to like take bad
examples or anything like that um but
you know I've done stuff like that as
well there's a lot of experiments that I
have going on that I do want to share
more maybe in the form of vlogs or
something like that and then obviously
there's the C++ series which is the
other big series on my channel which I'm
just gonna continue doing because that's
never gonna end there's nothing to
really be like okay I've covered all of
C++ that's impossible we have staples 20
coming out so everything of course is
changing and everything is getting more
complicated which is great but um
there's a lot of stuff going on um and
then I also mention that other kind of
fourth tier of things but I just want to
have like you know I've made videos in
the past about like you know how to be
productive for example I want to
continue doing kind of vlog style videos
like that as well
so we'll see how this kind of fits in
anyway I don't want to ramble on here
forever I think I've made my point let
me know in the comments below of what it
is that you want to see what makes you
excited what interests you the most I'm
sure this won't be our last video
talking about something like that the
game engine series officially I wanted
to bring it back next week however if I
end up doing the open shell batch
rendering video then trade that is like
part of the gamma gen series really
because those concepts are then going to
be integrated into the game engine
series so that would definitely be next
week I think I think I've said it all
hope you guys had a wonderful new year
and hope you're excited as excited about
this year as I am because you know it's
2020 it's the start of a new decade
let's go ahead and make some really cool
stuff I will see you guys later
[Music]